TOM WATKINS: Hi, everybody.
Thank you so much for coming.
My name is Tom Watkins
and I'm a product manager,
and I work on Android
Enterprise, specifically.
So I'd like to take the next
approximately 50 minutes
to take you through some of what
the team has been working hard
on, some properties
of the ecosystem
that we find make
it ideally suited
for some of the
enterprise deployments
that you and your
customers may have in mind.
And finally, we'll take a
look at some best practices
and a quick look
at what's coming up
in a future release
of the platform.
So firstly, some obligatory
large numbers to throw at you.
This probably isn't the first
slide full of large numbers
you've seen today.
It probably won't be the
last, maybe perhaps even
in my presentation.
The thing that I take
away from this slide,
in particular, is this
final statistic here.
This 82% of
smartphones, according
to a Gartner study late last
year, were shipping Android.
And we find that incredibly
powerful as a team working
on these enterprise features,
but also incredibly humbling.
When I talk to friends who,
perhaps, aren't in technology,
aren't in mobile technology,
specifically, there's
a very broad
spectrum of awareness
about Android as a
brand, and what it is,
and what it does for people.
But yet, I find it
incredibly powerful
that during those conversations,
if they reach into their pocket
and pull out a
smartphone, chances
are it's an Android smartphone.
Chances are it's capable of
running all of these management
modes, all of these policies
that I'll talk through,
and if it's not
already running them,
then it could be taken to a
BYOD deployment of their company
the next day.
We find that
incredibly powerful,
an aspect of the
platform, and we certainly
hope that you do too.
So that was on the overall side.
What about enterprise?
So another large number, or
percentage of a large number--
here, we see a bit of
room for improvement.
Obviously, it's not the 82%
statistic that you saw back
on the previous slide.
So the first and
most obvious area
that we want to
grow this number in
is doubling down on
our core features.
And I'll take you through
some of those core features
later on in the presentation.
But really making sure
that Android serves these
managed use cases
as well as possible.
That your employees, your
users are able to get up
and running as quickly and
as smoothly as possible,
and that they are
secured by default.
The other, perhaps
less obvious, direction
that we are growing in
is this figure, here,
caters for basically,
non-consumer usage
of the platform, B2B
sales of Android devices.
And so we want to make sure that
this works as well as possible
for all different use cases, no
matter what level of management
is required, and that your users
are able to be as productive
and secure as possible,
no matter what's required.
OK, enough of the
numbers for now.
What are we going
to look at today?
So firstly, I thought we'd
take a look at the ecosystem
overall, some properties
of the ecosystem
that I wanted to draw
particular attention to
in the enterprise space.
We'll look at some
of the form factors
that we see, some of the apps
and properties of the app
ecosystem.
Then we'll move
onto what Android--
the team that I work
on, what does Android
do in the enterprise,
and how can you
put these tools that we
put into the platform
to use within your organization?
We'll look at security.
We'll look at the two
main management modes
and what you can do with them.
Then we'll take a look
at some best practices
and wrap up with a look
at what the team has
been hard at working
on for an upcoming
release of the platform.
OK, so firstly, a
look at the ecosystem.
You never hear
mention of Android
without mention
of the ecosystem,
perhaps in the same breath.
The two are pretty
much intertwined.
Here are some properties that
I find particularly exciting
and particularly interesting
about Android as an ecosystem.
First is devices.
There is so much choice
of different devices
that you can put to
work for your users
and for your
particular use case.
You'll hear a lot about
the power of the cloud,
particularly in this
conference, and the tools that
are available there
to really serve
a lot of different large
compute requirements.
I think, actually, we
have one of the best
jobs within this ecosystem,
which is actually
getting to play with all
these physical devices
and making sure that--
helping our partners really
innovate and make sure
that there's a device
available to meet
pretty much any different
use case you can imagine.
There's a few different
verticals here
that are almost conspicuous
by their absence.
I've pulled out the
most traditional devices
and their appeal for
enterprise management,
but obviously conspicuous
by their absence
are whole verticals in auto
internet of things, obviously,
and TV.
So there's definitely more.
And the point that
I want to make
is that the diversity here is
definitely more than just price
point.
Its about having a device for
any particular different use
case that you have in mind.
Whether that's [INAUDIBLE]
a single purpose
deployment that you heard
my colleague, Vidia, talking
about earlier.
Whether its traditional
smartphone use case.
Whether its signage
or kiosk purposes.
There really is a device for
everything you can imagine.
Now with the scale and with
the diversity of the Android
ecosystem, it's easy to imagine
that some amount of complexity
may come with deploying
applications and managing
devices at this kind of scale.
And while that's certainly true,
the way that I look at this
is that Android provides this
platform, this underlying
layer of consistency,
where otherwise you
wouldn't be able to have.
For example, your same set of
developers write the same app
and have it run in a
consistent way across most
of these different devices.
They would have, but
wouldn't, perhaps,
be able to benefit from
the unified deployment
platform in Google Play.
And so there's a lot
that we do and is really
front of mind for the
Android team, in general.
And certainly, for
the enterprise team,
one of the areas
that we invest in
is ensuring that
these devices can
be deployed in a
consistent way to our users
and managed using a
consistent API surface.
So that's something
incredibly important to us.
I won't stand in front
of you today and pretend
that it's job done, there,
certainly a work in progress,
but that's something
that we find powerful
and hopefully you do to.
The final point that
I'll note is obviously
these devices are
capable of connecting
to so many different
cloud backends
that I'm sure you'll hear more
about later on in the talk.
But just from a raw
compute power perspective,
these devices are getting
so much more capable day in,
day out, that
certainly the flagship
smartphones that you come across
today are incredibly capable.
The software that runs
on them, the apps,
is only getting more and
more powerful over time.
And we're starting
to see these replace
a lot of general purpose desktop
kind of use cases already.
This is something that the
team is very excited about
and we see growing a
great deal over time.
OK, so a few more big
numbers, apologies.
This is about the Play platform.
It will be kind of remiss
to talk about the largest
mobile ecosystem in the
world without talking
about the largest
app distribution
platform in the world, which
is of course, Google Play.
Some of these numbers are
just astounding, I find.
65 billion-plus app
installs for Play.
I believe that was
in the past year.
A million-plus apps
available, unique
apps within the store to
serve all of the different use
cases you can imagine for
these different devices.
And a billion-plus 30-day
active users of Google apps.
That's Google apps
with a lower case a.
That's apps provided by Google.
And obviously, in the app
side of the ecosystem, the app
distribution side,
I'll talk a bit more
about this like what we
build into the Play platform
to help you manage these
deployments at scale, shortly,
but this is a key
area, again, where
we strive to bring
consistency to the ecosystem.
And finally, in
this set of slides,
a quick nod to all
of our partners who
make this possible.
Obviously this isn't the full
gamut of partners for Android
as an ecosystem,
but it's phenomenal,
and again, quite
humbling to think
that a lot of these
businesses, if not totally
put a great deal of--
are able to benefit a great
deal from the ecosystem at large
and provide for a great deal
of their business from it.
There's a partner
for almost any use
case in any deployment you
can imagine or set of partners
to come and enable that.
So we're immensely grateful
to our partners, some of which
I know are here today.
OK, so I don't need
to spend too much time
talking about the size and
scale of Android, perhaps.
Onto what we do and what
my team works on in order
to help you secure
these devices and get up
and running as
quickly as possible.
And again, the goal
that we focus on here,
first and foremost, is to
bring as much consistency
to the management and the
deployment of these devices as
possible, and be able
for your employees
to reach into their pocket
and pull out an Android phone,
and get them up and running
and productive in seconds.
So firstly, let's take a look
at what the platform provides.
How does it all fit together?
Really, on this
slide, the platform
is everything in the lower
right side of the diagram.
Everything that's
outlined in blue
here is stuff that the wider
enterprise team focuses on.
It's top of mind for us
and we provide toolsets
in each of these components to
help you get up and running.
From the platform perspective,
obviously the bottom block here
you see is the Android Open
Source Project, AOSP for short.
This is the really powerful
bit of the platform
that enables all of our
partners to extend and submit
contributions to Android,
an what really makes
it unique as a mobile platform.
Most of the stuff that
our team actually works on
goes into this AOSP
level of the platform.
That's the management
modes that I'll
talk through later-- the
provisioning, the policies that
get enforced.
Most of it goes into this
core underlying layer
that underpins everything else.
Immediately above
the AOSP layer,
you have Google Mobile
Services, or GMS for short.
And these provide
really everything
that is Google about
Android devices.
Some notable components that
you all have heard of in there
is Google Play itself.
There's a suite of security
components in there
that I'll talk a
little bit about,
and you'll hear more
about in some other talks
throughout the conference.
And so, these two
pieces as a whole
provide the core platform.
There's an API surface that's
exposed through these two
components, and we work with
our EMM partners, our Enterprise
Mobility Management partners,
who actually sit at the app
level just above this.
The EMMs provide an app which
is able to call these APIs.
They're really responsible
for setting up the devices
and choosing which policies
to enforce to really cater
for your particular deployment
or your particular vertical,
shaping that platform
into something
that's able to serve those use
cases as smoothly as possible.
Immediately above that we
have, again on the app side,
there's a suite of apps
that Google provide,
most notably Gmail,
Calendar, et cetera.
We as an enterprise team
put a huge deal of effort
into actually making sure
that the likes of Gmail
is able to get up and
running on whatever
email backend you may have.
If your company is using
Microsoft Exchange ActiveSync
as a stack, for example,
it's very important to us
that you are able to get up and
running on that using Gmail,
and we put a lot of
effort into having
your users be able
to get out of the box
and productive by default.
Likewise, the enterprise apps--
I highlighted the
million-plus different apps
available in Play.
This is a huge amount of
investment in diversity
that comes from the
ecosystem and is really
made possible from
our ecosystem partners
to serve all of these
different use cases.
Last but not least
on this slide,
we have a set of services
that the team invests in.
This is, most
notably, Google Play.
There's a suite of APIs that is
available to our EMM partners
to manage and deploy apps.
I'll talk a little bit about
how that function shortly.
And safety net, which is sort of
the broad term for the security
components that are bundled
by default in GMS Android
devices, which again, I'll
drill into a little bit
in an upcoming slide.
So here's a quick look at
where Android management has
come from and I'll finish up
by having a quick look at where
we're going.
So the first thing
to note, probably,
is that we've rebranded.
You probably won't see much
mention of Android for Work
anymore.
This was a rebrand, or
technically an unbrand,
back in December of last year.
And what's happened, how
the platform has evolved,
has really led to all
of these tools that
were previously known of
as being part of Android
for Work, as being
part of that offering.
They're now completely bundled
into any Android device.
So any Android device
that you pick up
will be capable of running--
a work-managed
device, for example,
will be capable of supporting
a profile as long as it's not
a low RAM device,
for example, and is
capable of deploying all
this uniform platform
policies throughout.
So the unbrand, we think, makes
a lot of sense in that respect.
It does make it slightly
difficult to actually talk
about what we as a team do.
So I'm thinking of starting a
nice little sideline of Android
for Work swear jar and I
think that will generate
a lot of profit,
if not just for me,
during the course of
this presentation.
OK.
So more about the team's
work and what we're up to.
So the first management
mode, if you like,
and the first capability
that we invested in way back
in Lollipop when we came
to produce what I'll
refer to as sort of the
modern set of management APIs
that are available,
is the work profile.
The work profile really allows
you to keep your employees'
data separate from--
keep your work data,
rather, separate
from your personal data
on these deployments.
We think that this is a
really powerful building
block for BYOD in particular.
So for example, just in order
to sync work data to the device
in order to be productive
as an end user who
owns their own device,
it's easy to imagine
that a lot of work data needs
to be synced, but also a lot
of what policy needs
to come with that data
to keep it secure.
And the work profile
really contains that data,
and the management
that comes with it,
and ensures that
nothing spills out
into the personal
side of the device.
So we find this incredibly
powerful for both end
users, who no longer need to
worry about management taking
over the rest of their
device, being able to wipe out
their personal apps and
photos or anything else,
and also for IT admins who don't
want the burden of thinking
about this aspect
of their deployment,
and thinking about
how users are going
to have to hand over
that much control
over their personal devices.
So some notable aspects of
the work profile and the
features that it provides.
If for whatever reason your
work data needs to be wiped,
most notably the profile
just disappears, the profile
and the work data
that goes with it.
You can have a separate
set of policies
that enforce the screen lock
complexity to get into the work
apps.
We find this is incredibly
powerful for most.
So family use cases.
You can give your device
to a friend or family
without worry about the
work data that's accessible
or on that device.
And they're
independently lockable.
The user is in
full control here.
So this is one of the
two management modes
here that we've put
in from Lollipop
and is available
in the platform.
The other is targeted for
corporate-owned devices.
So this is explicitly
anything that
is not owned by an end user.
This has a few different names.
Device Owner Mode is the
name of the API surface
that underpins everything here.
You'll hear me talk
about it as just
in the context of
corporate-owned devices a lot
as well.
And really the focus with
corporate-owned devices
is striving for maximum
flexibility and maximum
capability in terms
of the management
that you want to place on this
device, in terms of the use
cases that you
want to set it to.
And so you saw in
the devices slide
a while back the breadth
of different devices
that are available.
This mode really
caters for anything
from knowledge work on
a corporate owned device
all the way to fixed-purpose,
hotel check-in kiosks,
or special purpose devices.
So a very broad range
of functionality.
For example, notably you can
reset data on the whole device.
You can enforce policies that
affect Wi-Fi and the Bluetooth
stack, and so on and so forth.
You have a limited amount
of control of OTAs,
Over The Air updates.
When they hit the device
you can change a maintenance
window, which is
important for some
of our [INAUDIBLE]
use cases, to ensure
that your signage
situation stays up
and running when you want it to.
OK.
So next up in this
section, what do we
do as a team for Google Play?
And I think this is a
really powerful component
of the overall picture here.
Firstly, a little rebrand.
It used to be Play for Work.
Now it's Managed Google Play.
Some more contributions
for the Android for Works
swear jar, no doubt.
So this is another area where
we simplify and, we think, bring
a big investment in terms of
a common layer of management
and ability to
update apps common
throughout the ecosystem.
So the first thing
to note here is
that public apps, any of
those million-plus apps
that I talked to
you about earlier,
can be selected and curated as
an IT admin for your enterprise
deployments and for your users.
Those apps, once you've
selected and created
what's necessary
for your deployment,
you can use in conjunction with
your EMM partner and the Play
Management Console.
You can have those
apps pushed out
to your end user devices, push
installed inside a profile,
inside the workspace, or on
the managed device as a whole.
And you can have these
devices just up and running,
by default, as soon as--
the end user only
needs to set up
the basic level of
management on the device,
and the rest of that
deployment experience
can be taken care of for them.
And we find that
incredibly powerful.
Also, in terms of
facilities and feature
set from the Play
side of the stack,
you can have these
apps also updated.
You can do that
with private apps
just as well as you can
do it with public apps.
So if your use case requires,
for whatever reason,
apps that aren't available to
the public or even self-hosted,
privately hosted,
then again, you
can do this and use Play as this
unified stack for distribution.
Only the metadata, for example,
in the privately hosted app use
case needs to be
submitted to Play.
The last, and I find most
exciting bit of the puzzle
here, is configuration
at the app level.
So we have what's called
a Mobile Configuration
Management, or MCM for short.
And that allows these
enterprise applications
to take configuration through
the DPC, through the EMM,
and through the Play stack.
Wherever's most
convenient for you
to store that configuration.
And so this really
pieces together
to form a very coherent
and slick end-to-end
set-up experience, we find.
And so when your users
sign up and enroll,
then you'll not only have
the right apps to get up
and running and be productive
by default, those apps that also
contain a weird and wonderful
mix of different server
addresses, and ports,
and certificate names,
and whatever else, you name
it, configuration to get up
and running in your
enterprise environment, that
can all be supplied, by default,
to the apps through the stack.
So all the user needs to
enter is perhaps a password.
You can even leverage some
of our native apps, SSO work,
and maybe they don't always need
to enter their password either.
So out-of-box
productivity and speed
of deployment for the
end users is definitely
something that's top
of mind on our side.
Another thing that's top of
mind on our side is security.
So I'll just talk a
little bit about security
in this presentation.
I'd highly recommend, if you
didn't catch it this morning,
Adrian Ludwig, he's the
director of security on Android.
I highly recommend you
watch that talk on YouTube
when it becomes available.
And likewise, I'll plug
another talk tomorrow
with Edward
Cunningham, where he'll
dive into a lot
more detail about
what's available in the
Android security suite and how
that all fits together,
how that works.
So I highly recommend those two.
I'll just start by talking
a little bit about the scale
here.
This is from our upcoming
security year in review, 2016.
And the numbers are,
again, pretty large.
A billion-plus
devices protected.
This is out of the
box for GMS Android.
400 million device scans per
day and six billion-plus apps
checked per day.
So we noted in our
previous year in review,
that that probably
makes us the--
well, we believe
we are the largest
provider of endpoint
protection in the world
with these figures.
We're certainly the
least well known.
In terms of what that
means in numbers,
again, so these are the
rights of Potentially Harmful
Applications, or PHAs.
Again, much more detail
in the security sessions
about how those break down
in the different categories,
but essentially, for the
purposes of this talk,
we can consider them malware.
The first thing to note is
that the malware incidence
rates, the blue line here
for all sources of apps--
this is including
side-loaded apps,
and apps that come from
multiple different app stores,
and multiple geographies--
the incidence rates
are fairly low and declining.
This is the blue bar.
And even those other sources
of apps-- if you side
load an app on
Android, then you'll
still be protected by default
by something called Verify App.
So those apps are still
going to get scanned,
and still going to get
checked, and you will still
have prompts to uninstall, and
warnings for known bad behavior
in those apps.
So you see this number
decreasing, even
on the top line.
The bottom line,
again, probably more
relevant for a lot of
enterprise deployments,
is incidents rates from
using Google Play only
for your app distribution,
which are an order of magnitude
lower.
OK.
So onto some of
the best practices.
We have talked a little
bit about the tools
that we provide,
some of the features
that we provide in
Android as a platform,
how can you put them to use in
your customers' organizations
or in your own organizations.
This is quite a broad topic,
as you may have guessed.
So what I'm going to do is try
and sketch out some of the axes
by which we look at
these management modes,
and which you may be able to
imagine some of the deployments
that you're familiar with, and
how they fall on these axes.
So firstly, here you see the
horizontal axis that I've
drawn here is the
use of the device,
and the vertical axis is,
broadly speaking, the value.
And we go clockwise
round in terms
of the level of management
that is required
for this particular deployment.
In the bottom right
here, you have
what's basically a traditional
feature phone kind of segment.
There's little work data
synced to the device,
and hence, little management
and need for management.
This is an area
that I mentioned.
We want to make sure that users
benefit from the productivity
side, even if they don't need
the full heavyweight management
that comes with it.
This is where the traditional
stack starts to come in.
So the top of this
chart here, you
see the traditional knowledge
worker type use cases,
and that just ranges from
personal devices and the work
profile, all the way
through to managed
devices and our corporate-owned
device owner, API feature set.
And finally, everything on
the left-hand side of this
diagram--
this is all catered for with
our broad range of device owner
APIs, this whole vertical.
So anything that
is corporate-owned,
that is not personally
owned explicitly, this API
surface caters for
knowledge work all the way
down to your
fixed-purpose kiosks
that you may have heard about
in the previous session.
So that was a little bit
about how the API surfaces fit
together and how they can be
deployed within enterprise
that you may be familiar with.
A little bit of some general--
I'll have a look at some
general best practices
and then I'll talk
about pulling those out
in terms of who owns the device
on your particular use case.
So no surprises here.
You heard about the
instance rates of PHAs
when installing from Play.
We recommend that if your
deployment doesn't require it
as a hard requirement, that
you disable unknown sources.
You place all of your apps
within an apps distribution
channel that you trust and that
is useful for your deployment.
Device encryption.
So if you caught
Adrian's talk, you'll
have seen the statistics
and the prevalence
of device encryption, and
how it's increased over time.
I think it was 80%, he finished
up with, back in version
7 in Nougat of devices
now having encryption
enabled by default. So this
may not be top of mind any more
when you're thinking
about your deployments.
We recommend, nonetheless,
that you can enforce a policy
to require it, and we have
a surface of policies that
is able to do that for you.
Minimum security updates.
So again, the
security talk, this
is something that's really top
of mind for the security team.
There are policies that are
available to require and set
a minimum age, in terms of the
previous security update that
hit your particular device
that you're managing,
and we recommend
that you'll consider
enabling those for your fleet.
I'll talk a little bit more
about those in the next slide.
Excuse me.
We recommend that
when at all possible,
if appropriate for
deployment, you
would want to keep
your work data
and your personal data of your
employees on those devices
separate and managed separately.
Last but not least here, use
the latest management APIs
that are available with
a particular device.
So I mentioned earlier we have
what we call the modern managed
set of Management APIs that
came about with Lollipop Plus.
There aren't many
devices now that you'll
encounter in your average
enterprise deployments that
don't support those.
But we recommend instead of
treating the older device
admin API surface as, perhaps,
a least common denominator,
we recommend that you support
the latest and greatest when
it's available.
And if necessary,
for older devices,
if they're part of
your deployment,
your fleet, then you
can fall back gracefully
to that older API surface,
and perhaps bring with
it less privileged access
to less sensitive
information if that's
appropriate for your deployment.
And again, you can work
with your EMM partners
to decide where
that bar should be.
In terms of deployment
type, here I've
split it out in terms
of personally owned
and corporate-owned devices.
So again, no surprises here.
The management mode that
you should be looking at,
if you're looking at a
BYOD deployment, profile
owner versus device owner.
Security patches,
this is slightly
different in terms of your BYOD
versus corporate-owned devices.
So on the BYOD
side, you're going
to get a different range
of different devices taken
and activated within
your environment.
So what you can do here is
A, look at the security patch
level that's available
on this device.
Set, perhaps, a
cutoff or threshold
by which the age of the device
doesn't meet your requirements,
or that the security
patch level will not
give access to the most
sensitive resources.
And this is how we manage
devices at scale within Google,
for example.
On the corporate-owned
side, we recommend
that you look at OEMs who
are regularly shipping
these monthly security patches.
If this is important
for your deployment,
favor those devices.
For UX, we really look at this
through the lens of device
set-up and getting users up and
running as quickly as possible,
taking them to that value
as quickly as possible.
Turns out no users go to set-up
management on their devices.
Who knew?
They just go to
check their email
and get kind of frustrated
by the management that
gets in the way of it.
And so, this is something
that the team thinks
very hard about,
and we invest a lot
in minimizing the steps
required to get up
and running in the space.
We recommend that you will
enforce policies and work
with your EMM partners and your
app vendors to do the same,
and really take away any
hurdles, particularly
in the BYOD space, in the
personally owned devices,
to get the users up and
running extremely quickly.
Privacy.
We think with the work
profile API surface
that I mentioned
earlier, we think
we've set what we consider
a good baseline in terms
of privacy.
You have these two things,
these two worlds separated
by default, and there's
very little management
that is able to spill
outside of the work profile.
So we recommend
that that baseline
will be hopefully suitable
for your BYOD deployments.
We recommend you just
keep your users fully
informed about anything
that could, in fact, impact
that privacy.
Likewise on corporate
owned devices,
I'll take you
through some things
that we're working
on there to help
you inform your users
of any management that
may impact privacy.
OK.
So what is the team
hard at work on?
What's coming up next?
It's kind of the namesake
of the conference,
so I thought I'd better slip
in a few bits of information
about what you can expect in a
future release of the platform.
First and foremost, here
we have work profiles
are going to be available
for corporate devices.
So this is almost a merging
of the two worlds here.
What we found is that
the separation that
is enabled by work profiles
is immensely popular,
and it's immensely popular
not just in the BYOD space,
but also in corporate
deployments.
And these corporate
deployments don't
want to have full oversight
over the personal side
of the device,
over personal data,
but they do want
to allow the work
data to exist in
a separate space
and benefit from all of these
policies that we make possible.
You can define exactly
how data crosses these two
boundaries as an IT admin.
And we find this
really can improve
the usability that's possible
in corporate device deployments.
Closely related to a previous
feature and my note on privacy,
something that's upcoming
here is disclosures, reminders
if you like, of the fact that
A, the device is managed,
B, the name of the organization
that is managing this device
is not just on the lock screen
you see in this screenshot,
but a number of prevalent places
to remind the user that they're
not using a personal
unmanaged device.
They are using a
corporate device here.
And the second feature, the
second part of this feature,
is what we call the privacy hub,
here, on the left-hand side.
And this really
discloses any policies
that are in effect on the
device at this given point
or that could be put
in effect, and what
this device is capable of.
Some of the more
privacy-impacting actions--
for example, taking a bug
report, sharing a security log.
You can see when those
were last carried out
on this particular device.
And again, the goal
here is to help
you keep users fully informed
so that they can make the best
decisions about their privacy.
Device provisioning.
I mentioned this is a huge
area of focus within the team,
and it's something
we've invested a lot
in on the upcoming release.
A huge amount of investment.
In fact, this effort, here,
is focused on the BYOD side
of the spectrum.
So this is the work
profile set-up flow.
We really re-examined all of
the features and the components
that go into the work profile
set-up flow from the ground up.
It turns out it's
enormously complex
to have this secondary user
created on the Android device,
have the profile populated.
There's a lot of
server-side flows involved
in the set up of your average
profile deployment as well.
So we've reexamined all
of those dependencies, all
of those components,
and we've managed
to increase the speed of set
up by a factor of approximately
10x.
In fact, the maximum
here, the ceiling
is about 15 seconds, maximum,
on the most complex of our setup
flows.
The goal here is to get the
user to that value as soon
as possible.
What we've also
done and realized
as we've iterated on
the work profile concept
is that there's
really very little
to be scared of as an end
user in setting this up.
This is a benefit to the user.
It's a benefit to the admin.
And so what was previously
present in the flow
is a lot of different parties.
There's a lot of
different components
that are involved in
managing a device,
and each of those
parties tended to have
their own terms of service,
their own disclosures.
And that would inevitably lead
to a bit of a wall of text
and a wall of scariness,
for want of a better word,
that users were faced with when
they were setting these up.
What we've offered here
is an extensible surface
that you can use to populate
these terms and disclosures.
And so if the user's interested,
they can tap into View Terms
here and they'll see a
collapsible list of everything
that applies to their
usage of the profile.
That can come from your
organization, your company,
via the EMM, come from
the EMM itself, certainly,
from Google, and from parts
of the platform, and the OEM.
So all of those can
be consolidated now
into one screen.
So really,
provisioning is just as
simple on the platform
side as one screen
that you accept and continue.
So this is something
we're very excited about.
Other improvements
on the work profile.
So really, the goal
that we've set ourselves
here is to help admins
to really double down
on this API surface,
and look at areas where
management sometimes needs to
spill outside of the profile.
I mentioned that we
try to minimize that as
much as possible.
And the default answer
to anything spilling
outside the profile
is always no.
But there are some
legitimate cases
where you want to help ensure
the integrity of the rest
of the device, and so we're
putting some features in here
to really help with that
particular use case.
But still not impacting that
personal usage of the device
to the extent possible.
What we looked at here
and what we are launching
is Verify App strict mode.
So here, any warnings that were
present as part of the Verify
Apps process that
scans apps on install,
they can become
blocking, and they
can prevent potentially
harmful apps
from being installed on the
personal side of the device.
Likewise, we're coming out with
a lot of new APIs within Verify
Apps to inspect the integrity
and the status of any apps
that are installed within the
managed part of the device.
OK, data at risk protection.
So something I mentioned
earlier that's really
become prevalent and commonplace
throughout the ecosystem
recently is encryption.
So devices are now
benefiting from encryption
by default. They're
also benefiting,
as of the last
release, from what we
call file-based
encryption by default,
which is a lot more flexible
system for encrypting
these devices.
It allows, for example,
the device to boot up
and for apps to be what
we call encryption aware,
and for those apps to expose
whatever functionality
is necessary before
the rest of the device
or before the work
profile is decrypted.
So for example,
the common use case
here is that your
alarm will still
go off if your device is
rebooted during the night.
Or that DPCs can be
encryption aware as well,
and I'll talk a little bit
about some of the features
that that enables shortly.
So two headline items
that we've done here
and we've invested in,
in terms of doubling down
on the encryption
stack, credentials keys
can be ejected from memory on
the beck and call of the EMM.
So there's an API that
you can use, if necessary,
to eject these keys and have
that data at rest, completely
secure.
And likewise with strong auth.
So there are two types of
different authentication
that can protect a whole
device or a profile--
namely pin passwords or pattern.
And you can enforce
strong policies
on those types of encryption.
That's what's called strong
auth, strong authentication.
There's also other trust
agents plus fingerprints,
which are slightly less
strong, but they're
infinitely more convenient.
What we've done here
is exposed the policy
so that you can set the timeout
to require this stronger
form of authentication
as when you need it
for your deployments.
OK, so I mentioned about
file-based encryption.
What we've got coming up
here is a feature for FBE.
This allows for
file-based encryption keys
to essentially be--
or derived keys,
rather-- to essentially be
escrowed from the device.
And so, if your user
forgets your password
or if the enterprise portion
of the data on this device
needs to be recovered,
for whatever reason,
then you can use your
escrowed keys via your EMM
to actually reset the
screen lock password
of that encrypted volume.
And that's everything in
terms of new features.
Absent from this talk, this
presentation, was a few demos.
But don't take my
word for any of it.
We have the Android
management experience.
So you can take
any of the things
I've talked to today,
with the exception of some
of the up and coming stuff
that will be available shortly,
for a test drive.
Just go to the URL that
you've got on the screen there
and there's a whole
experience that you
can get your devices up and
running with these management
modes and try them
out for yourself.
So with that, I think we've
got a few more minutes left.
19 minutes left on
the clock for Q&A.
So feel free to ask me
anything that's on your minds.
There's a mic in the
front of the room
if you'd like to come up.
Or if you want to shout
out your questions to me,
I'll try to remember
to repeat them.
Hey there.
SPEAKER 1: Just a question
on the future stuff
that you've shown.
Are those going to be a mix
of Play services updates?
OS [INAUDIBLE] updates?
Or one or the other?
TOM WATKINS: So the question
was on the future-looking stuff,
will that be part
of the platform
or in the services
side of the stack?
And the answer is
it will be a mix.
Broadly speaking,
the new capabilities
for the devices, the new work
profiles on corporate devices,
that will be platform features
available in an upcoming
version of Android.
There is a lot that I mentioned
in terms of the security suite,
Verify Apps capabilities.
That's available in the GMS
Google Play Services stack.
So that will be
available on all devices
and be updatable out of band
from a platform release.
And I don't think I looked
at too many features
on the Play and the
service side of the stack,
but there is certainly
a bunch coming.
I focused more on the
traditional platform stuff.
So definitely a mix.
Thank you.
Hi there.
SPEAKER 2: [INAUDIBLE]
about the API
that you mentioned were upcoming
that were checking the security
[INAUDIBLE] or managed devices.
Any information you could
give about the future of--
TOM WATKINS: Yeah, sure.
So another plug for my
colleague, Edward Cunningham.
His talk is tomorrow
morning, I believe,
and he'll go into
a lot of detail
over what we call Safety Net,
which is the suite of security
services on the platform.
SPEAKER 2: [INAUDIBLE]?
Or are there other
things [INAUDIBLE]?
TOM WATKINS: Well,
safety net comprises
of Verify Apps and a handful
of other different services
within it.
So it's quite a broad category.
Again, from Adrian's talk, we
haven't invested a huge amount
in the branding of
these security features,
but it's just called safety net.
That's kind of what it does.
Yeah, I'd highly
recommend you look
at his talk for
details of exact APIs
that are going to be available
as part of that stack.
Hi.
SPEAKER 3: Do you
[INAUDIBLE] to iOS devices?
TOM WATKINS: So the
safety net stack--
most of our investment
in the Android team
certainly goes into the
Android side of the platform.
So the question, just
to repeat it here,
was can we expand
to iOS devices?
SPEAKER 3: Not safety net, but
the [INAUDIBLE] management of
[INAUDIBLE]
TOM WATKINS: This
is not something
that we're considering bringing
to iOS or other platforms
at this point, but we're
really excited about what
we are able to do on the
Android platform as a whole
and some of the use
cases that that enables.
SPEAKER 3: [INAUDIBLE] MDM
for iOS [INAUDIBLE] platform
for Android.
TOM WATKINS: Yeah, absolutely.
So I think our focus is
really on making Android
as usable and as
manageable as possible
for any different deployments.
And again, this is a very broad
spectrum in the Android world.
So our focus is definitely
on the Android side,
but I think we find that
features like the work profile
and, let's say, more
opinionated stances
that we've taken on how
device management should work,
we're quite proud of that
ability, that separation.
And so, we find that in some
cases and some deployments,
it makes Android
stand out when you're
looking to choose a platform.
But absolutely, and when
you're talking BYOD,
you've got to cater
for any device
that your users will bring.
So definitely
something that will
be top of mind for an IT admin
with your kind of deployment.
Thank you.
Any more questions?
I'll go over here.
Hi.
SPEAKER 4: [INAUDIBLE]
TOM WATKINS: So the question is
about certificate provisioning
as part of the setup process.
If you have a certificate
that you need to provision
on your device, how does that
work with profile separation,
for example?
And the answer is,
really, to a large extent,
you can treat the work
profile as a whole device.
And so there is a
separate key store
inside the work profile,
separately encrypted
with the file-based encryption.
And so, as part of that setup
process for just the work
profile, you can
have that certificate
provisioned into the work
profile side of the key store.
Likewise, we have a
VPN that's available,
just confined to the
profile or to specific apps
within the profile.
Is that helpful?
You're welcome.
Hi, there.
The back.
SPEAKER 5: Is there
a way to remotely
opt into a privacy statement
and to the terms of service?
[INAUDIBLE] EMM.
TOM WATKINS: Good question.
So the question is
can you remotely opt
into the privacy statements
when setting up a device?
The broad answer is no,
that's not something
that's possible today.
Particularly on
the BYOD side, we
want to make sure that end
users actually see this.
For what I mentioned earlier,
the upcoming feature, the work
profile that's going to be
available on corp managed
devices, we found that there
is certainly a strong desire
to have that set-up
pre-staged and executed
without an end user going
through it, necessarily.
So you can set up a work
profile silently just
on those corp-managed devices.
That's the feature that's
available on personal devices.
The end user is supposed to
be going through that flow.
Likewise, with initially setting
up the corp-managed device,
you will be required to see
one screen that gets accepted.
But there's a bunch of ways
that can be made very easy
and a lightweight process.
So you can NFC bump these
devices to set them up.
You can scan a QR code.
There's a bunch
of different ways
that you can set up
the corporate side.
But you will be tapping one--
SPEAKER 5: The end
user will [INAUDIBLE]
TOM WATKINS: You'll see one
screen, yes, for that flow.
Yeah.
Hi, there.
SPEAKER 6: Can you talk about if
any features for a [INAUDIBLE]
user where a device is shared
by [INAUDIBLE] employees,
and you can log in and
[INAUDIBLE] different
[INAUDIBLE]?
TOM WATKINS: So the question is
how do you cater for, I guess,
multiple user deployments
within a managed device sharing
the same Android device?
Now, I will say that, actually,
the strength of the Android
platform and the areas
that we invest most in
are single user use cases.
But with that said, there
are a certain number
of APIs on our device owner,
our corporate-owned API
surface that will help with
those kind of use cases.
So one in particular
is, I believe,
called Create and
Manage User, which
is part of the Device
Policy Manager class.
And that will enable certain
aspects of your deployment,
but I wouldn't say
that you're necessarily
going to have a full end to end
implementation possible, right
now, as of today.
But by all means, take a look
at the APIs that are available,
and the capability that's
there, and figure out
if it's sufficient
for your use cases.
SPEAKER 6: So
there's no way to tie
into like an operating system
user [INAUDIBLE] user account?
TOM WATKINS: So
the question was,
there's no way of tying
into multiple uses
on the operating
system back to--
this is more about an
identity kind of problem
with your deployment,
so you want
to have a particular
account associated with--
SPEAKER 6: [INAUDIBLE]
enterprise identity
and then go back and
[INAUDIBLE] sign into my bank
and I see the apps or
SalesForce [INAUDIBLE].
TOM WATKINS: I see.
OK, this is more of like
an SSO kind of question.
So yeah, depending on who
your identity provider is
and what type of accounts
you're talking about,
there are definitely
tools and features
available in the platform
that will support that.
What you might want
to look at is--
I forget the exact--
I think it's called Native Apps
SSO, which is a open standard
and we've shipped an
open library that's
available for Android and iOS.
Apple, yes, thank you.
And so, that's
available to log users
into multiple different IDPs,
multiple different backends,
and provide a common
standard at the app level
to get users signed
in seamlessly.
And that can be
configured, likewise,
via NCM, our
configuration management.
You can point it to
your IDP, give it
primers for your environments
and your tenant IDs,
for example.
So that should help with
these kind of deployments.
Does that answer your question?
Thank you.
Anything else in
terms of questions?
OK.
Well, thank you very
much for the time, guys.
[APPLAUSE]